jetzt kommt es zur letzten zum letzten
Tagesordnungspunkt einer aktuellen
Stunde von der beantragt von der AFD die
und damit gehen wir in die
Weihnachtspause mit einer aktuellen
Stunde zum Thema Nebenwirkungen der
corona-impfung sofort ernst nehmen die
Zahl der im Schäden hat ja zugenommen
der
wiesenen bzw der bewilligten impfscheine
Anerkennung der Impfschäden durch die
Versorgungsämter das ist der
unmittelbare Anlass und wir hören noch
mal Katrin göring-ecker zu konzentrieren
können und gebe das Wort an Martin
sichert für die afd-fraktion Martin
sicher von der afd-fraktion der jetzt
diese aktuelle Stunde begründen wird
Nebenwirkung der corona-impfung sofort
ernst nehmen
frau Präsidentin meine Damen und Herren
über 60 Millionen Menschen in
Deutschland haben sich impfen lassen im
Vertrauen darauf dass es nur ein kleiner
Pieks ist wie die Regierung es
versprochen hat diese 60 Millionen
Menschen waren davon ausgegangen dass
die Regierung alles unternimmt um ihre
Gesundheit zu schützen das sämtliche zur
Verfügung stehenden Daten zeitnah
ausgewertet werden und dass sie im Fall
eines Impfschadens schnell und
unbürokratisch Hilfe bekommen all das
ist nicht geschehen ganz im Gegenteil in
dieser Woche wurde jedem öffentlich
vorgeführt wie desolat der Umgang
öffentlicher Stellen mit den
corona-impfstoffen ist die
Kassenärztliche Bundesvereinigung
behauptet sie wissen dass es eine
Übersterblichkeit gäbe habe aber keine
Ahnung woher die Übersterblichkeit
kommen und man möge bitte nicht darüber
spekulieren aber eine Zusammenhalt mit
der Impfung können sie kategorisch
ausschließen dieselbe KBV die entgegen
ihren gesetzlichen Auftrag seit zwei
Jahren nicht in der Lage ist ihre Daten
das Robert-Koch-Institut und das
paul-ehrliche Institut weiterzuleiten
angeblich wegen einer fehlenden
Schnittstelle selbst vor hundert Jahren
wurden Informationen schneller
übermittelt
offensichtlich ist der Bundesregierung
der Schutz der Bevölkerung als auch ihr
gesetzlicher Auftrag völlig egal die
Bundesregierung gab zwar in zwei Jahren
über 100 Milliarden im
Gesundheitsbereich aus für Impfstoffe
Masken und Werbung war Geld in nahezu
unbegrenzter Höhe vorhanden ein paar
tausend Euro auszugeben damit ein
Programmierer sich ein paar Tage
hinsetzt um eine popelige Schnittstelle
zum Datenimport zu programmieren dazu
war die Bundesregierung hingegen nicht
bereit das bis heute der klare
gesetzliche Auftrag aus paragraph 13
Absatz 5 Infektionsschutzgesetz zur
regelmäßigen Übergabe und Analyse der
Daten ignoriert wird lässt nur einen
Schluss zu Herr Lauterbach hat mehr
Angst vor den Daten zu möglichen
entnehmen Wirkungen als vor Corona
selbst und das sieht man auch wunderbar
daran dass er sich als
Gesundheitsminister vor dieser wichtigen
Debatte heute drückt
[Applaus]
die Daten der KBV die so widerwillig
herausgegeben wurden dass ich sie erst
auf mehrfaches drängen überhaupt
bekommen habe zeigen diverse deutliche
risikosignale während andere
Todesursachen von 2016 bis 2022 relativ
konstant sind explodieren Todesursachen
wie plötzlicher Tod unbekannter Ursache
im Jahr 2021 auf das zehnfache die Zahl
der Impfreaktionen und
Impfnebenwirkungen sind im Jahr 2021 ja
auf das 30-fache gegenüber jedem der
Vorjahre angestiegen eine ganze Reihe
schwerer Erkrankungen die verschiedene
Krebsarten oder herzmuskelentzündungen
steigt ebenfalls 2021 deutlich an neben
den Daten der KBV sagt der berühmte
pathologieprofessor Schirrmacher dass
bei Obduktionen von bis zu zwei Wochen
nach der Impfung Verstorbenen bei 30 bis
40 Prozent die Impfung die Todesursache
war das ist alles nichts was man auf die
deine Schulter nehmen sollte
wir sagen weder dass die massive Zunahme
von herzmuskelentzündungen noch dass die
unerklärte Übersterblichkeit dieses Jahr
oder die Steigerung von unerwarteten
Todesfällen eindeutig auf die Impfung
zurückzuführen ist aber wir sagen dass
das deutliche risikosignale sind denen
sämtliche offiziellen Stellen umgehend
ergebnisoffen nachgehen müssen
wir brauchen endlich Aufklärung ich habe
diese Woche Daten der KBV und alle
Abgeordneten geschickt Kollegen von der
SPD haben sie mir zurückgeschickt das
zeigt sie wollen sich gar nicht damit
befassen es ist beschämend wie sie die
bedenkenlos eine Impfpflicht forderten
die Augen vor möglichen entnehmen
Wirkungen verschließen
und es schockiert mich wie seitens der
offiziellen Stellen mit den
risikosignalen umgegangen wird anstatt
ergebnisoffen die Daten zu analysieren
übertreffen sich die offiziellen Stellen
gegenseitig in Verschleierungstaktik da
erfreut es mich sehr dass Herr Sorge von
der Union diese Woche erklärt hat dass
impfnehmenwirkungen ernst zu nehmen sind
Herr Kubicki von der FDP ging sogar noch
weiter und forderte Obduktionen ich
möchte an dieser Stelle daran erinnern
dass FDP Union und AFD zusammen im
Bundestag eine Mehrheit haben zeigen sie
von der FDP zeigen sie von der Union
dass ihre Worte nicht nur leere
Worthülsen sind sondern sorgen Sie
gemeinsam mit uns dafür dass den
Ursachen für den Anstieg verschiedener
schwerer Erkrankungen und der
Übersterblichkeit endlich nachgegangen
wird
sorgen wir gemeinsam dafür dass
Impfnebenwirkungen und impfgeschädigte
endlich ernst genommen werden wir können
das gemeinsam die Unterstützung der AFD
ist Ihnen an dieser Stelle sicher
bald Martin sichert nochmal zu den
Fakten ihr Fazit hat das Ende Oktober
veröffentlicht innerhalb von fünf
Monaten haben sich die gesichert
festgestellten Impfschäden also die
anerkannten im Schäden von 64 auf 160
Fälle fast verdreifacht rechnerisch
kommt allerdings ein anerkannter im
Schaden auf etwa eine Million
verabreichte corona-impfungen
nächster Redner Martin mies von SPD ein
Zusammenhang zu konstruieren zwischen
Impfung und Todesfällen allerdings
entbehrt diese Konstruktion diese
Herleitung jeglicher Grundlage
die AFD macht das was sie immer tut sie
verbreitet Fake News und sie schadet
damit den Menschen in Deutschland und
die Zahlen auf die sich die AFD beruft
die gibt es wirklich allerdings sind sie
nicht aussagekräftig für das Thema was
wir heute behandeln und im übrigen genau
dieses Thema hat unser Minister Karl
Lauterbach vor zwei Tagen im
Gesundheitsausschuss aufgeklärt er war
mit allen Zahlen Daten Fakten vor Ort
hat Rede und Antwort gestanden und ich
danke ihm ausdrücklich dafür dass er
seine Zeit in diesem Moment nicht in
diesem Saal verschwendet sondern dass er
das tut wofür bezahlt wird nämlich für
die Gesundheit der Menschen in
Deutschland zu sorgen und das tut er
hervorragend
jetzt wollen wir aber trotzdem auch an
dieser Stelle nochmal aufklären was denn
die sogenannten datenexperten hier auf
der rechten Seite eigentlich gemacht
haben
grundsätzlich ist es so dass man wenn
man eine Stichprobe zusammenstellt sich
man dass man allein durch diese
Konstruktion der sich der Stichprobe
sich Ergebnisse schaffen kann wie man
sie sich erwünscht ein Beispiel schauen
wir uns mal diesen Saal an nehmen wir
die Menschen die sich aktuell in diesem
Saal befinden als Stichprobe wenn ich
jetzt auswerten will auf welche
Berufsfelder sich diese Menschen
verteilen dann prophezeihe ich ihn dass
ein übergroßer Anteil der Menschen in
diesem Raum
Bundestagsabgeordnete sind und damit
einen höheren Anteil abbilden als im
Durchschnitt der Bevölkerung
überraschend oder
so jetzt kommen wir zu dem was auf der
rechten Seite gemacht wird die
Datengrundlage die die AFD nutzt bezieht
sich auf eine Stichprobe die alle
Menschen umfasst die im Jahr 2021 beim
Arzt waren oder bei einer Ärztin um
diese Menschen geht es und dann wurde
sich angeschaut wie viele von diesen
Menschen sind gestorben im Jahr 2021 in
dem Jahr in dem sie beim Arzt waren und
was dann die AFD auch noch ausgewertet
hat ist wie viele Menschen von denen die
2021 beim Arzt waren im Jahr vorher im
Jahr 2020 gestorben sind
also wie viele Menschen was glauben sie
sind im Jahr 2020 gestorben und mir
gucken nur die Menschen an die ein Jahr
später noch beim Arzt waren die
Auswertung der AFD ergibt es waren 18
pro Tag also 18 Menschen pro Tag sind
ein Jahr vorher gestorben bevor sie zum
Arzt gegangen sind
so jetzt jetzt müssen wir mal ganz kurz
überlegen ja ich bitte um Konzentration
es gibt zwei es gibt zwei Möglichkeiten
Erklärung dafür die erste Erklärung ist
dass Menschen die gestorben sind ein
Jahr später wieder leben und zum Arzt
gehen können solche Fälle sind mir
allerdings aus dem Jahr 2020 nicht
bekannt ich kenne einen übermittelten
Fall die der liegt allerdings schon zwar
gut 2000 Jahre zurück weitere belegte
Fälle sind mir nicht bekannt
die zweite
die zweite mögliche Erklärung ist dass
Fehler im Datensatz vorhanden sind und
das ist der Fall und wie findet man das
raus ich habe diese Woche noch mal
intensiv mit dem Zentralinstitut der
kassenärztlichen Versorgung gesprochen
dort kommen nämlich die Zahlen her und
die Menschen die diese Daten erhoben
haben haben selbst gesagt leute passt
bitte auf da sind Fehler drin es gibt
sogar eine plausible Erklärung dafür
sind nämlich Eingabefehler es werden
jährlich hunderte Millionen Codes
eingetippt oft in großer Heilung oft
unter sehr großen Druck in den Praxen
und bei hunderten Millionen Eingaben
passieren auch Fehler und die führen
dazu dass dieser Datensatz auch dort
einzelne Daten fehlerhaft sind das eine
ganz einfache Erklärung und wer sich mal
zwei Minuten Zeit nimmt es rauszufinden
der findet es auch raus
ich liebe Daten der Minister liebt Daten
die Arbeiten mit Daten man muss sie
allerdings auch ein Tick richtig
interpretieren und in diesem Sinne
sage ich ihnen gebe ich noch mit auf den
weg denken Sie daran die Geschenke die
sie dieses Jahr bekommen bekommen sie
dieses Jahr ich wünsche schöne Feiertage
bis bald
möglicherweise macht es Sinn die Rede
von Matthias David mies von der SPD noch
mal in der Phönix Mediathek nachzuhören
wenn Sie nicht alle nicht alles
mitbekommen haben wird nicht in jedem
Gottesdienst gelingen das war der
Kommentar der Bundestagspräsident der
nächste Redner Stefan pilzinger von der
cdu/csu-fraktion
Sprecher für Gesundheit der
CSU-Landesgruppe die falschen
Horrorzahlen der AFD Titel die Welt am
15 Dezember über die Pressekonferenz des
afd-kollegen Mark Martin sichert vom 12
Dezember
corona-impfung kein Anstieg von
Todesfällen abzuleiten resümiert aktuell
die FAZ plötzliche Todesfälle warum die
afd-darstellung laut Fachleuten haltlos
ist erklärt das Online-Magazin Telepolis
vom 14 dezember erneut glaubt die AFD
einen investigativen Q zu landen und
ihren unerklärlichen Hass auf die
corona-impfung in eine im Skepsis der
Bevölkerung um zu Münzen zu können dass
sie dabei stet seriöse Daten seriöser
Institutionen missbrauchen wollen ist
eine absolute Unverfrorenheit so wie sie
in diesem Fall
Abrechnungsdaten der Kassenärztlichen
Bundesvereinigung die sie für ihre
Spielchen missbrauchen wollen dabei
haben die KBV selbst dass ihr
angeschlossen Zentralinstitut
für die kassenärztliche Versorgung und
andere echte Experten schnell und klar
feststellen können dass sie wohl bewusst
eine falsche Kausalität zwischen den
corona-impfungen und angeblich
exorbitant gestiegenen Todesfällen
herstellen wollten so kann es unter
anderem gar keinen punktuellen Anstieg
von vermeintlich plötzlich verstorbenen
impftoten um mehr als tausend Prozent in
Jahren 21 und 22 gegeben haben das ist
eigentlich ja völlig logisch da die
Impfung ja nicht zu einem einzigen
Zeitpunkt bundesweit gleichzeitig in
alle Bundesbürger verabreicht worden
sind sondern bekanntermaßen schrittweise
wenn die behaupte Kausalität stimmen
würde hätte der Anstieg von unerwartet
Verstorbenen geimpften konstant nach
oben gehen müssen und schließlich muss
man noch wissen dass die von den Ärzten
herangezogenen diagnosecodes nicht
unterscheiden zwischen verstorbenen
Patienten die geimpft waren und solchen
die nicht geimpft waren alles in allem
kommt das zi zum Ergebnis die Aufregung
um möglicherweise gestiegene Todesfälle
2021 in Bert jeglicher Grundlage die KPV
kommt da zum Schluss aufgrund von der
KBV und die AFD übermittelten über
rechnungs-schutzimpfung und Todesfällen
herstellen und statt sich demütig jetzt
zurückzuziehen und jetzt einfach mal die
Klappe zu halten sind sie dennoch so
unverfroren heute am Nachmittag des
letzten Sitzungstages vor
Weihnachtspause eine Aktuelle Stunde zu
diesen queren Verwirrung anzubauen viele
Menschen fragen sich da eigentlich haben
sie eigentlich noch alle Tassen im
Schrank
so noch mal ein
und uns als Union ist bewusst dass es
durchaus nicht wenige Fälle von
lungenkowith und von post-patienten gibt
diese oft nach oft noch jungen Menschen
die stark geschwächt sind und ihren
Alltag oft nicht mehr bewältigen können
müssen ernst genommen werden das sind
keine queren afd-spender sondern
Patienten die unser Mitgefühl und unsere
Hilfe brauchen
die Politik steht in der Pflicht die
Forschung rund um die Problematik und Co
wird und
post-möglichkeiten zu schaffen diesen
Bereich im Rahmen des Bundeshaushalts
2023 mit nur 21,5 Millionen rein für
Beratungsleistungen für betroffen
abzuspeisen ist ein Schlag ins Gesicht
der Betroffenen wir als Unionsfraktion
nehmen die Betroffenen Ernst stehen mit
ihnen im direkten Dialog und machen
Druck auf die Bundesregierung hier
endlich mehr zu tun um das Leiden der
Patienten zu minimieren
werte Kolleginnen und Kollegen der AFD
da sie sich ihr mit altgermanischen als
mit christlichen Bräuchen auskennen habe
ich für die anstehende Weihnachtszeit
ein Tipp für Sie wie Sie sicherlich
wissen ist am 21 Dezember das Fest der
Wintersonnenwende das Fest der
aufgehenden Sonne nutzen Sie dieses Fest
das Neuanfangs für einen Neuanfang für
klügere Anträge und Initiativen damit
wir Sie zukünftig zumindest inhaltlich
mehr ernst nehmen können liebe
Kolleginnen und Kollegen ich wünsche
Ihnen nun ein gesegnetes Weihnachtsfest
und einen guten Rutsch ins neues Jahr
vielen Dank für die gute Zusammenarbeit
Stefan pilzinger von der cdu/csu
Fraktion ist Sprecher für Gesundheit der
CSU-Landesgruppe Janusz Damen von den
Bündnis Grünen ist auch hier
sprechersprecher für Gesundheit wie es
in seiner Fraktion heißt
werte Kolleginnen Kollegen der
demokratischen Fraktionen sehr geehrte
Damen und Herren als Zuschauer meine
beiden
Vorrednerinnen haben schon sehr eloquent
vorgetragen warum diese aktuelle Stunde
in der Form und im Inhalt eine Zumutung
für alle Menschen in diesem Land ist sie
ist ganz besonders eine Zumutung für
alle Menschen im Gesundheitswesen die
aktuell aufgrund einer großen Anzahl an
gleichzeitigen Atemwegserkrankung RSV
Influenza Corona und weitere Viren
wirklich unter hochlaster daran arbeiten
Menschen gesund zu erhalten das
Gesundheitssystem am Laufen zu halten
und ich kann ihnen eins sagen egal ob in
der Pflege Ärztinnen und Ärzte andere
Gesundheitsberufe sie empfinden eine
Politik der Ordnung der Unwahrheiten der
Fake News die sich im Bundestag in
Redundanz wie eine gesprungene
Schallplatte diese ganze Woche mit
diesem Schwachsinn von ihnen auf der
rechten Seite befasst als Zumutung es
ist eine Zumutung für das Land es
ignoriert die Herausforderung es
ignoriert den Einsatz der Leute die
echten Probleme und ich kann Ihnen nur
sagen die Antwort da drauf muss wirklich
sein Denken sie doch wirklich mal
darüber nach was für ein Unfug sie wir
verbreiten die Kollegen haben schon
erklärt was ein Selektion weiß ist was
die Auswahl von Daten ist wie sie die
verdrehen in Unwahrheiten man kann den
Eindruck erwähnen ihre telegram-kanäle
scheinen leer zu sein ihnen scheint
keine Bilder mehr einzufallen deswegen
produzieren sie hier am laufenden Land
scheinbar neues Skandale die keine
Skandale sind ich will Ihnen auch sagen
warum sie haben hier einen Vortrag
vorgebracht und diese Woche an
verschiedenen anderen Stellen
offensichtlich auch schon erläutert der
zum Grunde liegt zu sagen sie hätten
einen total aufgedeckt mit Daten die
belegen würden die Impfung bringen
Menschen um und ich kann Ihnen sagen
anstelle einer ernstgemeinten Diskussion
über Nebenwirkungen und Wirkungen die es
bei jedem Medikament auch bei diesen
Impfungen gibt ist es so dass sie
Verunsicherung stiften weil sie weil sie
noch nicht mal wissen mit welchen Daten
ihrer dubiosen Experten sie hier
hantieren sie meinen aus
Abrechnungsdaten die der Liquidation
ärztlicher Leistung gehen irgendwelche
Kausalitäten über medizinische
Zusammenhänge Trend was für ein Unfug ja
Sie können nicht unterscheiden zwischen
dem was Abrechnung ist und dem was
medizinische Dokumentation ist und das
sei ihnen auch noch gesagt neben
Abrechnung medizinischer Dokumentation
gibt es noch eine sterbefallstatistik
die auch ein dritter Bereich ist der
völlig unabhängig ist von dem was sie
analysiert haben sie analysieren also in
einem Teich in dem es den Fisch den sie
fangen wollen gar nicht gibt falsche
Daten stehen falsche Schlüssel es ist
unerträglich über den die Verunsicherung
die sie damit stiften und letzter Punkt
auch das scheint ja für sie
offensichtlich ein Problem in der
Analyse von Daten und den
verständniswissenschaftlicher Fakten zu
sein der Zusammenhang von Korrelation
und Kausalität scheint ihn wiederholt
auch in diesem Zusammenhang in keinster
Weise geläufig zu sein eine Korrelation
könnte zum Beispiel sein dass man sagt
dort wo die Umfrageergebnisse ihrer
Partei am rechten Rand besonders hoch
sind ist die Impfrate widrig und wo die
impfte hatte niedrig ist da sind viele
Menschen gestorben mehr Menschen als in
anderen Teilen wo die Menschen viel
geimpft waren das wäre eine Korrelation
wo man auf den Eindruck kommen könnte
möglicherweise könnte ein Zusammenhang
sein der Unterschied der unter der
Unterschied zwischen zwischen einer
solchen Korrelation die keine Kausalität
ist ist dass ich Ihnen sagen kann die
Wissenschaft hat eindeutig bewiesen dass
diese Impfung schützt dass diese Impfung
mehr Nutzen bringt dass diese Impfung
obwohl es ins Leben Wirkung gibt obwohl
es im Reaktionen gibt in der Nutzen und
Risiko Abwägung ein wichtiges
entscheidendes und das beste Instrument
ist was uns aus der Pandemie rausgeführt
hat was viele tausend Menschenleben
geschützt hat und sie scheinen nicht
bereit zu sein entscheiden diese
wissenschaftlichen Fakten anzuerkennen
sondern zu ihrem eigenen Vorteil zu
ihrem eigenen Vorteil auf dem Rücken
aller Menschen und dem wohl dieses
Landes zu versuchen Fake News und
falsche Daten zu verbreiten das ist
schändlich und ich will ganz deutlich
sagen lassen sie uns zurückkehren zu
wichtigen Debatten in diesem Parlament
über die Zukunft unseres
Gesundheitswesen über die Ausrichtung
wie wir den Fachkräftemangel bekämpfen
wie wir die Krisen unserer Zeit
gemeinsam bekämpfen und nicht falsche
Informationen in diesem Parlament die
politische Arbeit aufhalten vielen Dank
ich wiederhole nochmal die wichtigsten
bekannten Fakten zum Thema stand Ende
Oktober dieses Jahres laut Frankfurter
Allgemeinen Zeitung 160 anerkannte Fälle
von Impfschäden das bedeutet statistisch
gesehen ein anerkannter impfstaaten auf
gut eine Million verabreichte
corona-impfungen nächste Rednerin Katrin
Vogel von den Linken mit viel
interpretierten und manipulierten Daten
haben wir ja vorhin schon gesprochen
ja Impfnebenwirkungen existieren es gibt
auch schwere im Schäden in sehr sehr
seltenen Fällen aber das ist kein Grund
deswegen auch eine Impfung gegen das saß
Kopf zwei Virus zu verzichten denn die
Risiken einer coronaerkrankung
überwiegen die Risiken einer
corona-impfung bei weitem allein gestern
starben wieder 100 43 Menschen im
Zusammenhang mit Corvette
190000 leiden an longkowitz oder Post
das Virus greift offenbar ganz
unterschiedliche Organe an und wir
verstehen immer noch viel zu wenig wie
ist das eigentlich tut und was man
dagegen tun kann aber anstatt darüber zu
sprechen wie wir Menschen Leben und
Gesundheit der Bevölkerung schützen
können vergeudet die AFD hier wieder
unsere Zeit um damit um gegen die
Impfung zu polymisieren und die
Verunsicherung in der Bevölkerung zu
führen und das ist eine Schande die
Kolleginnen und Kollegen ich habe damals
vorbereitet ich habe meine Grafik
mitgebracht
eine Grafik die den Zusammenhang
herstellt zwischen Impfquote und
Übersterblichkeit denn an dem ganzen
falschen Zeug was sie erzählen ist er
eins richtig wir haben eine deutliche
Übersterblichkeit in einigen
Bundesländern das sind aber genau die
Bundesländer in denen ihre Propaganda
auf fruchtbaren Boden gefallen ist und
wo sie mit der Verunsicherung der
Menschen dazu beigetragen haben dass
wenige sich haben impfen lassen die sind
nämlich hier oben hier unten ganz am
unteren Ende bei der Übersterblichkeit
ist das kleine Bundesland Bremen wo ist
die Linke Gesundheitssenatorin Claudia
Bernhard geschafft hat mit einer
vorbildlichen Aufklärungskampagne für
eine außerordentlich hohe Impfquote zu
sagen jetzt reden wir mal ein bisschen
über Logik ja ich weiß dass ich bei
ihnen da wahrscheinlich keine offenen
Türe Einrede aber reden immer über Logik
mir erscheint es logisch dass wenn im
Bundesländern mit niedriger Impfquote
die Übersterblichkeit hoch ist
und das in und in Bundesländern mit
hoher impote die Übersterblichkeit
niedrig ist das ist da ein Zusammenhang
geben könnte der aber genau umgekehrt
aussieht wie das was sie die Leute
glauben machen wollen nun wissen wir ja
dass die AFD
davon ausgeht wenn es Deutschland
schlecht geht dann geht es der AFD gut
das heißt ihr Ziel ist es Menschen so zu
verunsichern dass Sie das was Ihnen
persönlich und ihrer Umgebung gut tun
würde nicht mehr machen nämlich sich
impfen zu lassen und sich vor der einer
Infektion zu schützen und damit auch vor
lang anhaltenden möglichen
Gesundheitsfolgen so jetzt will ich aber
jetzt nicht nur über die AFD reden ich
habe noch zwei Minuten die muss ich
leider den anderen Parteien hier im Haus
noch mal widmen weil warum ist es denn
so dass die AFD so einfach es schafft
Menschen zu verunsichern und da müssen
wir wirklich mal über die Ökonomisierung
unseres Gesundheitswesens und über die
Profitorientierung im Gesundheitswesen
reden die nämlich dazu führt dass viele
Menschen den Institutionen in diesem
Land nicht mehr Vertrauen und das ist
einfach ist ihnen zu
unterstellen dass
Wissenschaften nur
mietmouler sind Wissenschaftlerinnen und
Wissenschaftler sich nur nach dem
orientieren wofür sie womit sie den
meisten das meiste Geld verdienen können
und wenn die Leute sehen das mit
Steuergeldern Forschung finanziert wird
deren Erträge dann in die Taschen von
Privatleuten fließt mit Versicherten
Geldern Klinikkonzerne in
dreistelliger milliar Millionenhöhe
Dividenden im private taschentauchen das
verunsichert dann schon und deswegen
finde ich Herr Lauterbach hat vollkommen
Recht wenn er sagt wir müssen die
Ökonomisierung
Ökonomisierung im Gesundheitswesen
zurückdrängen und wenn er das wirklich
angeht dann wird er die Unterstützung
der Linken hat haben aber da ich da
bestimmte Zweifel habe werden wir ihm
auch ganz genau auf die Finger gucken
und werden Druck machen dafür dass auch
wirklich was passiert denn wir brauchen
eine Revolution im Gesundheitswesen
und ich möchte an dieser Stelle allen
Menschen die über die Feiertage in
Krankenhäusern Pflegeeinrichtungen in
den Rettungsstellen in
notarztpraxen dafür sorgen dass kranke
Menschen mit Pflegebedarf unterstützt
gepflegt und geheilt werden den möchte
ich gute Weihnachten wünschen ich
wünsche Ihnen friedliche Weihnachtstage
und meinen Kolleginnen und Kollegen hier
auf der rechten Seite bessere
Erkenntnisse
soweit Katrin Vogler von der Fraktion
DIE LINKE nächste Rednerin ist jetzt
Christine Aschenberg Prognose sie ist
Mitglied im
Mitglied im Bundestags
Gesundheitsausschuss und Mitglied der
FDP-Fraktion vielen Dank Frau
Präsidentin liebe Kolleginnen und
Kollegen ja es macht mich wirklich
fassungslos und ja auch wütend in
welcher Art und Weise wir uns in dieser
aktuellen Stunde mit dieser Thematik mit
dieser an sich wichtigen Thematik
beschäftigen allein der Titel suggeriert
ein völlig falsches Bild einerseits über
die impfz Zulassungen und andererseits
über den Umgang mit im Nebenwirkungen
sie von der AFD bewirken damit nur eins
sie befeuern weiter
Verschwörungstheoretiker wahrscheinlich
ist es das was Sie erreichen wollen und
das finde ich einfach nur schäbig meine
Damen und Herren
Deutschland und auch Europa sehen die
Transparenz als sehr wichtigen Baustein
in der Gesundheitsversorgung nur so
können Vertrauen in medizinische
Produkte erlangt werden das gilt ganz
besonders auch für Impfungen aus diesem
Grund müssen nicht nur während des
zulassungsprozesses für einen
impfstoffumfängliche Daten über die
Wirkungsweise und die Sicherheit erhoben
werden sondern auch weit darüber hinaus
dabei ist die nutzenrisikoabschätzung
der Zentrale Entscheidungspunkt ob ein
Impfstoff eine Zulassung erhält oder
nicht erhält dann der Impfstoff die
Zulassung für den deutschen
Arzneimittelmarkt werden neben der
pharmazeutischen Qualität natürlich auch
die Daten über unerwünschte
Nebenwirkungen erfasst meine Damen und
Herren diese Daten sind übrigens für
jeden Bürger auf der Internetseite des
Paul-Ehrlich-Instituts frei einsehbar
das nenne ich die richtige und wichtige
Transparenz in unserem Gesundheitssystem
meine Damen und Herren
zusätzlich sind die Zulassungsinhaber
des Impfstoffes gesetzlich aufgefordert
in regelmäßigen Abständen aktualisierte
unbedenklichkeitsberichte anzufertigen
und ist dem Paul-Ehrlich-Institut zu
übermitteln in diesem Bericht müssen
aktuell verfügbare Sicherheitsdaten
enthalten sein aus denen sich weiterhin
eine positive nutzenrisikoabschätzung
ableiten lässt ist das nicht möglich
beeinflussen die aktuellen Daten die
nutzen Risikoabschätzungen negativ kann
selbstverständlich auch die Zulassung
widerrufen werden das wäre
beispielsweise der Fall bei verstärkt
auftretenden hochgradigen
Impfnebenwirkungen ist aber bisher noch
nie eingetreten meine Damen und Herren
sowohl niedergelassene Ärzte als auch
der öffentliche Gesundheitsdienst melden
Impfnebenwirkungen anders paul Ehrlich
Institut sowie an das Robert
Koch-Institut wieder die notwendige
Transparenz so soll es sein so läuft es
auch und das können wir nun der
Bevölkerung immer wieder sagen diese
Impfstoffe sind sicher bereits im Sommer
2022 hat die afd-fraktion ja für
Aufregung gesorgt als sie von 2,5
Millionen Fällen gemeldeter
Impfnebenwirkungen bei corona-impfungen
berichtete
leider haben sie es versäumt es auch in
Vergleich zu den tatsächlichen Impfung
das sind nämlich über 154 Millionen in
fällt ins Verhältnis zu setzen und zum
anderen müssen sie haben sie auch
vergessen zu erwähnen dass als häufigste
Impfnebenwirkungen die Schmerzen an der
Injektionsstelle codiert werden nämlich
bei 92 Prozent der Teilnehmer das ist
eine Codierung wie wir aber alle wissen
ist dass keine impft Nebenwirkung sie
wird zwar als dessen aufgeschrieben aber
keiner der hier sich hat impfen lassen
egal ob das jetzt gegen Grippe oder
Corona ist lässt sich doch für ein zwei
Tage Schmerzen in Arm nicht impfen das
muss man doch mal ganz klar sagen also
das Verhältnis setzen dieser Zahlen ist
völlig daneben was sie hier tun
ja außerdem ich habe es gerade schon
gesagt diese diese impf diese dieses
Schmerzen an der Impfstelle sind kein
neues im Phänomen jeder kennt ist der
sich gegen Grippe impfen lässt so wie
ich das auch jedes Jahr mache ja diese
Daten aber dafür zu instrumentalisieren
um Sorge und Angst in der Bevölkerung zu
schüren meine Damen und Herren das finde
ich einfach nur widerlich und das muss
man hier ganz deutlich mal sagen vor
wenigen Tagen sorgten wir die AFD dann
erneut für für Rohre indem sie eine
dramatische Zunahme der Sterbefälle auf
den Tisch brachte Fachleute aus dem
wissenschaftlichen Institut der AOK
sowie dem Zentralinstitut der
kassenärztlichen Versorgung kam aber zu
einem völlig anderen Ergebnis ich
zitiere aus dem Statement des
Zentralinstituts für die kassenärztliche
Versorgung die Aufregung um
möglicherweise gestiegene Todesfälle
2021 entbehrt jeder Grundlage ist es
kein Anstieg plötzlicher Todesfälle
unbekannter Ursache festzustellen meine
Damen und Herren erneut
instrumentalisiert die afdaten um Angst
und Schrecken in der be Änderung zu
Verbleib zu verbreiten das ist nicht nur
verachtend das ist auch ein Schlag ins
Gesicht je derjenigen Menschen die
tatsächlich geimpfnebenwirkungen haben
das muss man doch mal ganz klar sagen
anstatt hier eine sachliche Debatte zum
Umgang mit Impfnebenwirkungen anzustoßen
werden hier einfach nur
Katastrophenszenarien heraufbeschworen
die auf gar keinen Fall der Realität
entsprechen ich bitte Sie eindringlich
dass sie uns künftig von dieser Art von
Debatten verschonen die Gesundheit der
Bevölkerung ist zu wichtig um sie mit
Fake News in einer aktuellen Stunde zu
versehen ich danke Ihnen und wünsche
allen Kolleginnen und Kollegen ein
schönes Weihnachtsfest und ich hoffe wir
sehen uns alle gesund und munter im
neuen Jahr wieder vielen Dank
Christine Aschenberg Duck muss von der
FDP nächste Rednerin Christina Baum von
der afd-fraktion ebenfalls Mitglied im
Gesundheitsausschuss
[Applaus]
[Musik]
frau Präsidentin meine Damen und Herren
in Anbetracht der nun bekannt gewordenen
vielen teils schweren Nebenwirkungen und
Todesfällen durch die corona-injektion
stellen sich viele Menschen die Frage
wie konnte es überhaupt dazu kommen wie
konnte es dazu kommen dass ich so viele
Menschen ein Medikament haben
verabreichen lassen dass unzureichend
erforscht und zudem auf einen ganz neuen
Wirkungsmechanismus beruhte so dass man
es niemals hätte Impfung nennen dürfen
die Antwort erinnern sie sich an der
Strategie Papier aus dem
Bundesinnenministerium das im März 2020
veröffentlicht wurde
darin hieß es unter anderem um die
gewünschte Schockwirkung zu erzielen
solle man Kindern Schuld am Tod ihre
Angehörigen zu schreiben der Existenz
dieses Papieres vor dem
Gesundheitsausschuss sogar geleugnet man
will von dieser Ungeheuerlichkeit nun
nichts mehr wissen
bereits im April
13 April 2020 wie es ich darauf hin dass
durch diese gebetsmühlenartige
Wiederholung dass Menschen und das
menschenmassenhaft Sterben die Bürger
durch Angst gelähmt werden und damit für
den nächsten Schritt bereit gemacht
werden sollen die zwangsimpfung
dieses systematische Angst und
Panikmache wurde gezielt eingesetzt um
selbst eine der schwersten Verletzungen
unserer Freiheitsrechte durchzusetzen
das Grundrecht auf körperliche
Unversehrtheit ein nicht unerheblicher
Teil der Bevölkerung hat Herrn
Lauterbach allerdings auch vertraut
dabei sagten sie selbst sagt Herr
Lauterbach selbst bei einem Interview
mit der arbeitsschool of public im Juni
2020 würden Sie bitte genau zu dass
mrna-impfstoffe vielleicht das mRNA
Impfstoffe vielleicht funktionieren doch
bis jetzt haben sie am Menschen
verabreicht noch nie funktioniert sie
kamen niemals zum Einsatz sie haben Herr
Lauterbach hat also die Menschen bewusst
getäuscht indem er eine Sicherheit
vorgegaukelt hat die es so niemals gab
die Folgen der sogenannten Impfungen
sind jetzt jedenfalls nicht mehr zu
Leuten selbst die Regierung Treue Presse
kommt nicht mehr um hängt davon zu
berichten auf zwei neue Studien möchte
ich sie dann machen ein Inter
disziplinierungs-team der Uni Basel
untersuchte die Auswirkungen der
moderner Impfung auf den Herzmuskel das
Ergebnis knapp drei Prozent der
Studienteilnehmer erlitten eine leichte
Herzmuskelentzündung die damit also
tausendmal häufiger vorkommt als bisher
mit
0,003 Prozent angegeben es wurde auch
zugegeben das ist keine Regeneration
eines Geschädigten Herzmuskels gibt auch
nicht bei leichterentzündung das
bedeutet dass die Betroffenen
irreversibel für ganzes Leben schwer
geschädigt sind drei Prozent die zweite
Studie die Herr Lauterbach in einem
Twitter-Beitrag selbst erwähnte stammt
aus den USA sie bestätigt dass das
Risiko von Langzeitschäden nach einer
corona-infektion mit jeder weiteren
ansteigt gerade auch für geimpfte
Personen das bedeutet nichts anderes als
vergessen und auch die letzte der drei
Begründung für eine Impfung wegfällt die
des Schutzes vor schweren Verläufen es
gibt ihn nicht so wie es auch keinen
eigen und keinen fremdschutz gibt
man muss deshalb von einem vollständigen
Versagen dieser
mrna-injektion sprechen aus diesen
Fakten ergeben sich mindestens folgende
vier Forderungen
erstens diese unwirksame aber in vielen
Fällen schädliche Impfungen muss bis zum
Beweis des Gegenteils sofort eingestellt
werden zweitens alle kritischen Ärzte
und Wissenschaftler die dies
vorhergesagt haben müssen nun endlich
rehabilitiert und entschädigt werden für
den Rufmord den man an ihnen begangen
hat drittens die Verfehlungen der
verantwortlichen Politiker und Behörden
müssen in einem Untersuchungsausschuss
aufgearbeitet und einer juristischen
Bewertung zugeführt werden und viertens
und letztens Herr Lauterbach sollte
lieber seinen stuhlräumen als
Gesundheitsminister denn er ist eine
Gefahr für die Bevölkerung vielen Dank
soweit Christina Baum von der AFD in der
Aktuellen Stunde die ja von ihrer Partei
ja Entschuldigung ihrer Fraktion
beantragt worden ist über Nebenwirkungen
der corona-impfung
Nebenwirkung der corona-impfung sofort
ernst nehmen so lautet der genaue Titel
nächste Rednerin Heike Engel hat von der
SPD
sehr geehrte Frau Präsidentin sehr
geehrte Damen und Herren Dr Christinas
Märchenstunde
sehr dünnes Eis auf dem die
Antragstellerin sich hier bewegt sehr
sehr dünnes Eis wenn sie da nicht mal
gleich einbricht sie sagen hier dass wir
endlich anfangen müssen Nebenwirkungen
bei Impfungen ernst zu nehmen damit
fördern sie etwas was wir immer schon so
machen wie bei jedem Medizinprodukt dass
wir in Deutschland zulassen werden
Nutzen und Risiken sehr genau abgewogen
und Nebenwirkungen sehr ernst genommen
nicht ohne Grund wurden die Impfstoffe
in Deutschland erst deutlich später
zugelassen als zum Beispiel in Israel
damit wir zunächst weitere Informationen
sammeln konnten auch wurden nicht alle
Impfstoffe immer auch für alle Gruppen
freigegeben sie können sich sicher sein
meine Damen und Herren von der AFD dass
die Ständige Impfkommission hier eine
gute und gewissenhafte Arbeit leistet
was sie allerdings mit ihren komplett
unwissenschaftlich zusammen kopierten
Zahlen behaupten das sind glatte Lügen
und entbehren jeglicher Ernsthaftigkeit
und Vertrauenswürdigkeit
sie versuchen einmal mehr die Menschen
zu beunruhigen sie spielen mit der
Gesundheit der Menschen ganz getreu ihre
Motto den Menschen in Deutschland muss
es schlecht gehen damit die AFD Erfolg
hat aber den Gefallen tun wir Ihnen
nicht Frau Baum sie haben gestern in
einem Interview Verständnis für die
Reichsbürger geäußert wir werden alles
dafür tun dass sie als parlamentarische
Arm der Reichsbürger und Nazis schnell
wieder in der Versenkung verschwinden
sie sind schuld am Tod von Walter Lübcke
sie sind schuld an dem Attentat von
Halle ihre Kollegin wollte dieses Haus
bewaffnet stürmen und ich weiß nicht wie
viele ihre Kolleginnen ähnliches
Vorhaben so und jetzt noch ein Wort zu
Ihnen Herr sichert
Siegburg Querdenker Freunde als
Sachverständige einladen und dann deren
Auftritte im Bundestag oder im Ausschuss
als Nachweis für eine Bedeutung dieser
Personen anführen ihr sogenannte
datenanalyst komm lauten ist nicht mehr
als ein Scharlatan sie und ihre Partei
sind einfach nur peinlich und mehr Zeit
verschwende ich auf ihren Antrag nicht
aber ich wünsche allen DemokratInnen
hier im Haus schöne Weihnachten und
alles Gute fürs neue Jahr vielen Dank
hat jetzt das Wort für die
cdu/csu-fraktion
[Applaus]
sehr geehrte Frau Präsidentin liebe
Kolleginnen und Kollegen als ich gestern
Nachmittag den aufsetzungsantrag der AFD
zu Gesicht bekam mit dem Titel
Nebenwirkungen der corona-impfung sofort
ernst nehmen kam mir auch sofort in den
Sinn dass man wirklich etwas ernst
nehmen müsste und zwar den Umstand dass
wahrscheinlich bei der AFD ein massiver
Anfall von Amnesie vorliegt oder
erinnern Sie sich nicht mehr
an die Debatte im vergangenen Juli mit
einem Antrag der den Titel trug
impflebenwirkungen erklären ernst nehmen
vielleicht zur besseren Auffindung
Drucksache 20 25
67 in der wir alle hier mit großer
Ernsthaftigkeit den damals schon
abstrusen Gedanken versucht haben
Rechnung zu tragen und ihn zu erläutern
was der Unterschied zwischen
Impfreaktionen und im Komplikationen ist
und dass die Interpretation des ICE der
icds von ihnen geradezu an den Haaren
herbeigezogen waren und jeder Grundlage
entbehren okay ich muss einräumen
diese Erklärungsversuche sind
gescheitert das wundert uns nicht
wirklich weil sie gar nicht bereit sind
sich mit diesen Fragen
auseinanderzusetzen nun gibt es etwas
aktuelles hier und heute dass dieser
aktuelle Stunde rechtfertigen würde der
Blick in die Entwicklung seit Juli
ergibt allerdings nichts was sie
begeistern wurde in der Tat etwas das
sind aber nicht die Fantasien die sie
jetzt wiederum auf die ICD
Interpretation verwendet haben sondern
das ist vielleicht eine interessante
Botschaft für die Bürgerinnen und Bürger
zu Hause dass sich das bei sehr
gewissenhaft mit den Impfnebenwirkungen
möglichen im Wirkungen und damit mit den
Interessen der geimpften beschäftigt das
hat eine App aufgelegt die App safe fact
2.0 mit der eine Beobachtungsstudie ins
Leben gerufen worden ist die
rekrutierungsphase der interessierten
lief am 30.09.20
ab und immerhin
730.000 Interessierte haben sich doch
registrieren lassen und geben noch
freiwilliger Basis Angaben zur
Verträglichkeit der Impfung bei Ihnen ab
und es gibt eine gewisse
Wahrscheinlichkeit dass ein möglicher
impfgeschädigter nicht ankündigungslos
Umfeld und verstirbt sondern im Vorfeld
Ankündigungen in der Befindlichkeit
geben könnte insofern ist diese
Untersuchung überaus nützlich und sie
kann für die weitere Betrachtung der
Verträglichkeit der Impfung
hervorragende Information liefern die
App bleibt in den nächsten 12 Monaten
geöffnet und sie wird vor allen Dingen
fließend ununterbrochen in die
nebenwirkungsdatenbank des
Paul-Ehrlich-Instituts eingepflegt und
dort wiederum tauchen auch die akuten
Erkenntnisse in den Verdachtsmeldungen
beziehungsweise in den
sicherheitsberichten der nächste steht
jetzt zum Ende dieses Jahres an
veröffentlicht wie schon mehrfach
geäußert dass paul Ehrlich Institut
arbeitet mit höchster Transparenz
Nachvollziehbarkeit und jeder jeder der
nur ansatzweise
den Eindruck hat eine dauerhaft des
Unwohlsein durch die Impfung erlitten zu
haben kann dies über www
nebenwirkungen.de
andersbau ehrlich Institut melden und es
wird dort unverzüglich verarbeitet trotz
aller Bemühungen Professor psychotec in
irgendeiner Form Vermutungen oder
Spekulationen in den Mund zu legen hat
dieser in seiner bekannten
wissenschaftlichen Sachlichkeit in allen
Anhörungen und Fragestellungen den
unterstellungsversuchen der AFD
gekontert hat diese bestanden und hat
immer wieder zum Ausdruck gebracht dass
eine seriöse wissenschaftliche Analyse
der uns allen und weltweit durch die WHO
vorliegenden Erkenntnisse überhaupt
keine
Vermutung für eine atypische Entwicklung
insbesondere eine Übersterblichkeit
aufgrund der Impfung rechtfertigen
wollen dies ist
für uns eine solide Basis der Analyse
des impfgeschehens an dieser Form der
Aufarbeitung und der weiteren Begleitung
werden wir uns verantwortlich
orientieren und uns im Ausschuss mit
Sicherheit ununterbrochen
informieren lassen und mit Rücksicht auf
das Bedürfnis aller Anwesenden möglichst
schnell zu den Angehörigen
zurückzukehren spende ich den Rest
meiner Redezeit den demokratischen
Parteien in diesem Haus vielen
herzlichen Dank und ein frohes
Weihnachtsfest danke schön
nach dieser Rede von Georg kippels von
Unionsfraktion ein kurzer Hinweis von
mir wir werden die Aktuelle Stunde
wahrscheinlich nicht in voller Länge
übertragen können weil wir um 15 Uhr zu
einer live-pressekonferenz des
Bundesfinanzministers schalten werden
nach der Sitzung der stabilitätsrats da
geht es um etwas um was uns alle angeht
einerseits um die Zustand des
Bundeshaushalts wie auch der
Schuldenbremse und der
Staatsverschuldung ab 15 Uhr dann auch
live bei Phoenix zunächst aber von den
Bündnis 90 Maria kleinschmike im Haus
ich bin sehr dankbar über den Verlauf
dieser aktuellen Stunde wenn ich sehe
alle Rednerinnen und Redner aus den
demokratischen Parteien haben hier sehr
sehr deutlich gemacht dass das was die
AFD hier wieder erneut versucht
keinerlei Basis hat insgesamt Fuß zu
fassen sie versuchen auf ganz viele Art
und Weise verschiedenste Daten so zu
verknüpfen dass sie ihre These das
nämlich das Impfen schädlich sei hier
propagieren können und das einzige Ziel
um dass es ihnen geht es geht darum
Angst zu schüren und gleichzeitig gegen
diesen Staat zu mobilisieren das ist
ihrer Ihr Interesse und alle hier sind
vereint darin dass wir Ihnen das nicht
durchgehen lassen
und
ein bisschen zurück
Januar 2020 der Beginn der corona-krise
was wir erlebt haben welche Bilder wir
gesehen haben wie wir Menschen haben
sterben sehen wie wir überforderte
Krankenhäuser gesehen haben wie wir aber
auch erleben mussten wie viele Menschen
die uns anvertraut waren die sehr
verletzlich sind insbesondere alte
Menschen in Einrichtungen verstorben
sind und wenn sie sich dann anschauen
was wenn sie sich dann anschauen was
dann passiert ist dass in so kurzer Zeit
Impfstoffe entwickelt worden sind die
dazu geführt haben dass wir am Ende des
gleichen Jahres erstmalig einen
Lichtblick hatten erstmalig darauf
vertrauen konnten dass es Hilfe gibt
dass wir da rauskommen können und wenn
sie sich gleichzeitig ankommen anschauen
wie viele Leben gerettet worden sind
gerade von Menschen in
Alteneinrichtungen beispielsweise dann
sehen Sie wie wertvoll es war dass wir
diesen Weg beschreiten konnten und das
ging nur mit einer gemeinschaftlichen
Anstrengung aller in dieser Gesellschaft
aber auch weltweit und das in Frage zu
stellen das alleine schon ist ist etwas
wofür sie sich verantworten müssen das
zweite ist wenn Sie sich anschauen was
wir insgesamt geschafft haben wenn sie
heute schauen wir haben alle nicht mehr
eine durchgreifende Angst vor Corona wir
wissen dass es Medikamente gibt für
wissen dass es den Corona Impfschutz
gibt und wir wissen auch welche Regeln
wir einhalten müssen um möglichst mit
dieser Pandemie leben zu können auch das
ein ganz ganz wichtiger Schritt der auch
wieder Normalität in diese Gesellschaft
gebracht haben und genau das versuchen
sie immer wieder zu hintertreiben sie
versuchen aus der Angst vor Corona aber
auch aus der Meinung von von Maßnahmen
ihr Kapital ihr politisches Kapital zu
schlagen und genau das macht hier keiner
im Raum mit
und ich will jetzt die restliche Zeit
nicht für ihren Mist nutzen sondern
davor dahin gucken was wir tun müssen
weil natürlich haben wir noch große
Probleme wir haben eine Vielzahl von
Menschen die longkowith erkrankt sind wo
wir noch nicht wirklich wissen wie wir
zu einer durchgreifenden Hilfe kommen
können da müssen wir unsere Anstrengung
hinstellen da müssen wir etwas tun und
das werden wir als Ampel auch tun das
werden wir mit dem nächsten
Versorgungsgesetz anpacken genauso wie
wir schon die Forschung in diesem
Bereichen ausgebaut haben da muss die
die Richtung hingehen und nicht
rückwärts wie sie das machen und
Richtung ernst und natürlich muss es
auch darum geben die wenigen Fälle die
es gibt wo Menschen tatsächlich einen
Schaden aus einer Impfung erworben haben
dass wir damit umgeben dass wir auch da
genau wie bei longkowith danach schauen
wie können wir da zu ausreichender
Therapie und Hilfe kommen auch das ist
ist natürlich eine Aufgabe und auf der
Grundlage muss es weitergehen in dieser
Art und Weise
wissenschaftsbasiert sehr gewissenhaft
und immer mit dem Ziel vor Augen dass
wir allen nutzen wollen und gleichzeitig
allen danken die hier sich in diesen
zwei Jahren so massiv für das Wohl aller
eingesetzt haben in dem Sinne denke ich
drücken wir den Dank an alle im
Gesundheitswesen an dieser Stelle noch
mal besonders aus und ansonsten wünsche
ich Ihnen ein friedliches Weihnachtsfest
Liebe ZuschauerInnen liebe Zuschauer sie
haben es oder Sehens bei unserem
Bildschirm
das auf der linken Seite in Kürze
erwartet wird die Pressekonferenz des
Finanzministers zur haushaltsstabilität
wir werden da live drauf gehen der
drittletzte Redner der Aktuellen Stunde
möglicherweise der letzte der
Live-Übertragung von Phoenix ist jetzt
Lars Lindemann von der FDP
lieber Kolleginnen und Kollegen ich
möchte
nachdem sie liebe Kollegen von der AFD
hier gefordert haben man möge sich
sofort mit den Folgen der Impfung
beschäftigen und uns hier auch
vorgeworfen haben das würde in
Deutschland nicht ergebnisoffen
stattfinden vielleicht noch mal eine
zweite Dimension einer dritte einführen
nachdem alle Vorredner hier zu dem Thema
der Daten der Bewertung glaube ich
ausreichend gesprochen haben sie Frau Dr
Baum diskreditieren in diesem Land mit
der Art wie sie hier vorgehen 400.000
Ärzte
100.000 Medizinstudenten die jeden Tag
mit ihren Lehrenden genau über dieses
Problem sprechen die in diesem Land
leben Familie haben sich über das Thema
welche Folgen hat diese Pandemie für uns
jeden Tag auseinandersetzen 36
Universitätskliniken 108 Universitäten
422 Hochschulen und 5.000
Wissenschaftler pro eine Million
Einwohner in Deutschland beschäftigen
sich mit der Frage und sie wollen hier
unterstellen dass diese Gesamtheit nicht
in der Lage ist sich mit den Folgen auch
einer solchen Impfung vernünftig
auseinanderzusetzen wie verrückt ist das
eigentlich
ja und ich will Ihnen noch genau zu dem
Thema noch was sagen Frau Baum sie sind
nicht nur Abgeordneter und tragen ein
freies Mandat und sind hier nur im
Gewissen unterworfen sie sind auch
Ärztin und sie sind eben nicht nur ihren
Patienten verpflichtet sondern eben auch
dem Gemeinwohl und dass das in diesem
Land so ist dass wir Ärzte haben die
nicht nur den Patienten nämlich einem
dritten verpflichtet sind und dem
Gemeinwohl sollten Sie sich sehr gut
überlegen wie sie die Dinge hier
vortragen und in dem Zusammenhang will
ich hier auch noch mal darauf hinweisen
dass es gut ist dass wir in diesem Land
unser Gesundheitssystem so konstruiert
haben dass es von Freiberuflern getragen
wird die genau diese gemeinwohlbindung
und die Konzentration
ja das glaube ich Ihnen aber ganz
offensichtlich hat das nicht dazu
geführt dass sie in der Lage sind diese
Verantwortung auch wahrzunehmen
und wenn man darauf schaut dann will ich
an dieser Stelle sehr deutlich sagen es
ist in Ordnung und gut nach Auffassung
meiner Fraktion dass unser
Gesundheitssystem genauso organisiert
ist das Freiberufler die ausschließlich
ihren Patienten und ihrem Gewissen
verpflichtet sind und eben auch dem
Gemeinwesen das Vergessen immer viele in
ihrer Berufsordnung steht dass sie dem
Gemeinwesen verpflichtet sind sich mit
diesen Fragen beschäftigen in dieser
Breite und das gelingt am allerbesten
und das ist in Deutschland auch geglückt
in den letzten 30 40 Jahren dass das
Ärzte im Wesentlichen auch in einer
gewissen ökonomischen Unabhängigkeit tun
und an dieser Stelle möchte ich wenn sie
mir das erlauben in meinen letzten zwei
Minuten vielleicht noch Einsatz sagen
dass im übrigen ist auch der Grund warum
wir uns gesundheitspolitisch zum
Beispiel mit euch Fragen beschäftigen
sollten wann es in diesem Land endlich
eine modernisierte geoe gibt damit das
weiterhin funktioniert und bei dieser
Gelegenheit möchte ich die Beteiligten
der Verhandlung auch auffordern die
zügig mal vorzulegen und auch deutlich
sagen dass wir in diesem Zusammenhang
auf diejenigen schauen die den Patienten
verpflichtet sind und dann in zweiter
Linie denjenigen die für
Kostensicherheit in dieser Debatte
sorgen wollen am Ende wünsche ich Ihnen
allen gesegnete Weihnachten für
diejenigen die Weihnachten nicht feiern
wünsche ich Ihnen eine ruhige Zeit die
Gelegenheit schließen Sie all diejenigen
in ihre Gebete oder auch Überlegungen
einen die nicht in einer so sicheren
Welt wie wir leben über die Dinge
nachdenken können über die wir heute
hier haben auch sprechen müssen
gesegnete Weihnachten und alles Gute
ja noch lassen sich hier
Bundesfinanzminister Christian Lindner
und die
länderfinanzministerinnen und
Finanzminister Zeit im Stabilitätsrat
deswegen bleiben wir hier auch noch im
Bundestag nächster Redner in der
Aktuellen Stunde zur Nebenwirkung für
von corona-impfungen von der
Unionsfraktion bitte
nee das ist nie vom vorne
so jetzt wird eine persönliche Erklärung
von Christina Baum von der afd-fraktion
wohl gewünscht die Wolle Daten
Rednerpult gehen das geht allerdings nur
vom Platz aus
vielen Dank als er das letzte Mal durfte
ich eine persönliche Erklärung von da
vorne abgeben das ist aber nicht üblich
wir machen es vom Platz gut okay also
ich möchte diese Aussage die in Bezug
auf meine Person zu den reichsbürgen
abgegeben werden wurde nicht so stehen
lassen ist nämlich falsch ich habe
gestern in einem Interview dazu gesagt
dass auch dieser Menschen zu unserer
Gesellschaft gehören und das niemand aus
unserer Gesellschaft auszugrenzen ist
dass wir uns im Gegensatz dazu mit den
Meinungen auseinandersetzen müssen so
wie sich das in einer demokratischen
Gesellschaft gehört denn die Gedanken
sind nicht weg nur weil wir sie
ausgrenzen oder nicht hören oder nicht
sehen wollen die rote Linie ist die
Anwendung von Gewalt all das habe ich
gesagt und dazu stehe ich danke schön
ja soweit die persönliche Erklärung von
Christina Baum zu ihrer Rede die sie
hier gehalten hat und jetzt Tino Sorge
ist der nächste vorletzte Redner der
Debatte möglicherweise jetzt der letzte
Redner bei uns wir sehen es auch gleich
wann es zur Pressekonferenz mit
Christian kommt Dinos Sorge von der
Unionsfraktion und Kollegen es ist ja im
Vorfeld auch von meinem also als
Kollegin das kann ich jetzt nicht ganz
vielen Dank bitte das zu entschuldigen
liebe Kolleginnen und Kollegen also der
weihnachtliche Übermut ist hier ein
bisschen durchgekommen bei dir deine
Ernst wir haben ja von den vorrätern
auch von meinem Kollegen Georg Kipp ist
schon gehört das Thema Lebenszeit ist
ein ganz wichtiges für uns alle und
insofern können wir jetzt darüber
diskutieren ob das uns diese Debatte
nicht eine Menge Lebenszeit hier auch
stiehlt und deshalb will ich gar nicht
so darüber sprechen was Sie hier alles
wieder zum Besten gegeben haben sondern
ich will darüber sprechen was sie hätten
tun können ich hätte gerne hier in
diesem Plenum darüber diskutiert wie wir
Menschen helfen können die diese fünf
Nebenwirkungen die Impfreaktion die
Impfschäden haben die hätten darüber
sprechen können wie Daten besser genutzt
werden können wir hätten darüber
sprechen können wie diese Daten besser
aggregiert zusammengeführt werden können
wir hätten darüber sprechen können wie
wir Strukturen verbessern aufbauen die
eben genau diesen Menschen helfen die
jetzt sagen ich habe das Gefühl ein
Impfschaden eine impfkommunikation
impfnebenwirkung aus dieser Impfung
heraus zu haben aber ich habe das Gefühl
mir hilft keiner und das was sie hier
tun liebe Kolleginnen und Kollegen der
AFD sie helfen niemanden sie stehen uns
nur die Zeit und deshalb
deshalb will ich auch noch mal darauf
eingehen der ein oder andere Kollege
Kollegin im Vorfeld hat ja schon darauf
hingewiesen wann kann natürlich aus
diversen Statistiken alles herauslesen
sie greifen sich irgendeine kleinst
gehorte raus extrapolieren die und
vergleichen die mit irgendeiner
Bezugsgröße da können sie de facto alles
irgendwie kommunizieren aber es wird in
der Sache ja nicht richtiger und wenn
sie mal zugehört hätten was die KBV
gesagt hat was das peige gesagt hat dann
hätten sie doch erkennen müssen dass das
was sie hier wieder mal skandalisieren
wollen überhaupt kein Skandal ist
sondern dass die Daten Fakten Zahlen die
sie hier bringen einfach falsch sind
falsch interpretiert und das nehmen sie
leider nicht zur Kenntnis liebe
Kolleginnen und Kollegen deshalb finde
ich es ja auch immer so bemerkenswert
dass dann auch für diese Nachweise der
angeblichen skandalösen Dinge die sie
hier vortragen ja immer nur ihre
diejenigen glaube ich datenanalyste in
der Lausen anführen also ich weiß nicht
er nennt sich selbst Daten analist für
mich ist das ein Daten Salafist nehmen
sie es übrig äh liebe Kolleginnen und
Kollegen
und insofern würde ich gerne auch und
das können wir gerne zukünftig auch
machen verstärkt über diese Themen
sprechen ich gebe zu wir müssen da alle
besser werden auch bei der Kommunikation
nach außen wir müssen solche
Befindlichkeiten solche Probleme ernst
nehmen es geht nicht darum dass wir eine
Gruppe gegen die andere ausspielen dass
wir sagen diejenigen die sagen sie haben
im Schäden erlitten die gelbes nicht
insofern war das auch überhaupt nicht
hilfreich das will ich ja auch mal sagen
dass einige Kollegin und Kollegen und
auch unsere Gesundheitsminister gesagt
haben diese Impfung sein
nebenwirkungsfrei also insofern glaube
ich sollten wir da auch ein bisschen in
der Diskussion abrüsten sondern
natürlich jede Impfung hat
Nebenwirkungen aber die Chancen einer
Impfung überwiegen bei weitem impfen
Impfung Sitten Segen für die Menschheit
es ist ja die angesprochen worden ob das
jetzt poppen ob das Kinderlähmung war
also wirklich ein Segen für die
Menschheit und deshalb sollten wir das
nicht schlecht reden und sollten auch
der Eindruck erwecken als liefe jeweils
gegen den Baum im wahrsten Sinne des
Wortes liebe Kolleginnen und Kollegen
deshalb will ich jetzt auch meinem
vorrednerkollegen dem Georg kippels
gleich tun und will die Lebenszeit die
uns auch durch diese mehr oder weniger
fragwürdige Debatte gestohlen worden ist
an sie zurückgeben ich wünsche Ihnen
allen eine schöne Weihnachtszeit ein
paar besinnliche ruhige Tage hoffe Sie
können viel Zeit mit Ihren Lieben mit
ihren Familien verbringen und hoffe sie
alle im nächsten Jahr wieder gesund und
munter hier wiederzusehen in diesem
Sinne vielen Dank für Ihre
Aufmerksamkeit
nichtsdestotrotz es gibt noch einen
Redner den letzten Redner nicht nur
dieser Debatte nicht nur diese Sitzung
Tage sondern voraussichtlich des
gesamten Jahres 2022 das ist Rupert
Stühle von der SPD-Mitglied im
Unterausschuss globale Gesundheit liebe
Kolleginnen und Kollegen Liebe
Zuschauerinnen und Zuschauer auf der
Tribüne und als letzter Redner in der
letzten Debatte dieses Jahres kann man
ja ein bisschen über seine
besten Erlebnisse in diesem Parlament
berichten und eins davon
nie wieder hier oben
auf Köln unseren Debatten Folgen können
ich fand das beeindruckend als ich zum
ersten mal gesprochen habe dass sie
tatsächlich sitzen zuschauen und wieder
unseren Debatten mitverfolgen können und
wenn wir hier über Wirkungen reden dann
ist es auch eine Wirkung der Impfung
eine Wirkung der Masken eine Wirkung
davon dass wir ein großer Anzahl in
diesem Lande aufeinander Rücksicht
genommen haben wegen der Pandemie und
deswegen finde ich es ein gutes Zeichen
dass sie in dieser letzten Debatte
dieses Jahres in diesem Plenum auch mit
dabei sind also für Kinder
und dann will ich noch etwas dazu sagen
eigentlich wollte ich nicht viel zu
Wirkung Ihres Antrags sagen aber mein
Wahlkreis ist der Wahlkreis in dem auch
Frau masak Winkelmann kandidiert hat ich
saß mit der im Wahlkampf auf
unterschiedlichen schulpodien und ich
finde
ihre Partei wollte dass diese
Verschwörerin wieder in den Bundestag
einzieht dass sie hier wieder in diesem
Gesundheitsausschuss sitzt und ich fand
das bedrohlich im Rückblick mit ihr auf
zahlreichen schulfolien zu sitzen
insofern finde ich das bedrohlich wenn
jetzt aus ihren rein das immer noch
Verein
immer noch verharmlost wird was da an
Verschwörung der reichsbürgerinnen und
Reichsbürger passiert ist und dann
lassen Sie mich
zu noch etwas kommen in dieser Debatte
als Letzter Rede an dieser Debatte habe
ich mir auch angeguckt wie das Jahr 2022
eigentlich angefangen hat und auch da
haben wir in der ersten Debatte im
ersten Lebenswoche über das Thema Corona
geredet und ich finde das zeigt eins
dieses Jahr war natürlich von der
Pandemie geprägt und dieser Deutsche
Bundestag hat sich in seiner ganz ganz
großen Mehrheit kontrovers auf Fakten
gestützt und ernsthaft mit diesem Thema
auseinandergesetzt und da ich jetzt
forschungspolitiker bin und nicht im
Gesundheitsausschuss sitzen möchte ich
mich da bei diesen Kollegen aus dem
Gesundheit Kolleginnen aus dem
Gesundheitsamt auch bedanken dass sie
das ganze Jahr so gemacht haben und ich
finde es richtig dass sie das in weiten
Teilen
aufgrundlage von wissenschaftlichen
Fakten gemacht haben
wenn natürlich hat
Corona eine Wirkung wir sehen das gerade
wenn wir uns mit longkurved und
postkorbit beschäftigen wenn wir darüber
reden wie wir die Forschung zu meccsf
und den Fragen zu lankowitz unterstützen
und beschleunigen können wir haben das
übrigens gemacht im letzten Jahr und
auch in den nächsten beiden Jahren haben
wir dazu Programme geteilt natürlich hat
die Impfung eine Wirkung auch das ist
doch so wenn wir uns die ernsthaften
wissenschaftlichen Studien angucken dass
das nicht zu bestreiten ist dass die
Impfung eine Wirkung hat und zwar eine
positive Wirkung für dieses Land und
natürlich hat es auch gesagt worden gibt
es im folgenden Nebenwirkungen und
übrigens schwere lebenwirkungen bei
1.000 Impfungen sind es 0,3 schweren
Nebenwirkungen die anders paul Ehrlich
Institut gemeldet werden und dann war es
diese letzte Debatte so richtig noch ein
paar Minuten schenken möchte
würde ich eine 30 Sekunden noch habe ich
einen Nikolaus mitgebracht weil ich
finde das Thema Impfen hat auch was mit
dem Thema Weihnachten zu tun ich würde
das der Präsidentin schenken weil
bestellvertretend für alle anderen hier
wenn man impfen ist es so wenn dieser
Zeit ja
manchmal geht es in dieser Zeit um die
kleine Geste und manchmal geht es nicht
um einen selber sondern diese kleine
Geste wie das Impfen hat auch eine große
Wirkung auf andere insofern wünsche ich
uns allen gemeinsam eine gute
Weihnachtszeit kommen sie gut ins neue
Jahr und ich freue mich darauf Sie im
nächsten Jahr wiederzusehen vielen Dank
[Applaus]
liebe Kolleginnen und Kollegen die
Aktuelle Stunde ist beendet ich möchte
an dieser Stelle im Namen des Präsidiums
und ich glaube auch in ihrer aller Namen
noch einer ganzen Reihe von Leuten
danken nämlich zum Beispiel den
Technikerinnen und Technikern die es
überhaupt möglich machen dass wir hier
immer reibungslos Tagen können
natürlich auch der plenarassistenz und
allen weiteren Mitarbeiterinnen
Mitarbeitern des Grund der Verwaltung
den Stenografen und Stenografen die
alles festhalten auch wenn Ihnen
vielleicht manche in den Ohren klingt
den Polizisten und Polizisten die nicht
immer eine leichte Zeit hier gehabt
haben auch in diesem Jahr ein ganz ganz
herzliches Dankeschön allen die das
wirklich machen und ich möchte mich auch
bei den Zuschauerinnen und Zuschauern
hier bei uns im Saal aber natürlich auch
vor den Bildschirmen bedanken für das
Interesse und in diesem Sinne auch bei
den Journalistinnen und Journalisten mit
auf die wir ja auch ein Stück angewiesen
sind über ihre
Berichterstattung und manchmal auch mit
einem Stück Humor zum Beispiel mal bei
der heute-show können wir ja auch mal
sagen auch das gucken wir ja in Zeit
gerne mal also allen noch mal herzlichen
Dank und damit kann ich sagen wir sind
am Schluss unserer heutigen Tagesordnung
und ich berufe die nächste Sitzung des
Deutschen Bundestages ein auf Mittwoch
den 18 Januar
2023 und 13 Uhr ich wünsche Ihnen allen
eine besinnliche Zeit eine ruhige Zeit
es ist die ruhigste Zeit des Jahres
finde ich werden wir merken aber ich
hoffe dass sie alle gesund und munter
ins neue Jahr starten können und wir uns
hier auch gesund und munter im Januar
Wiedersehen die Sitzung ist geschlossen
kommen sie gut nach Hause
ja damit hat Adam osus als amtierende
Präsidentin auch das phönix-team im
Bundestag für dieses Jahr verabschiedet
das war die letzte Live-Übertragung hier
aus dem Plenum aber liebe ZuschauerInnen
liebe Zuschauer das heißt nicht dass wir
am Ende sind im Gegenteil Phoenix sendet
immer es gibt viel zu berichten diese
Woche auch in unserem Weihnachts
Sonderprogramm ab nächster Woche bleiben
Sie bei uns und ich gebe damit zurück
nach Bonn ins Phönix Studio zu Ines
Arland